Eine forschungsgruppe hat mehrere erdbeben in der region, leipzig untersucht und kommt zu einem beunruhigenden
Ergebnis demnach könnte es dort größere erdbeben. Geben die zerstörungen anrichten
Könnten, eben in deutschland eigentlich verrückt aber offenbar doch möglich klicks, um, science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das sind keine guten nachrichten die da vom deutschen geoforschungszentrum
Kommen das forschungsteam hat zwei erdbeben aus den. Jahren 2015. Und 2017 näher untersucht und ist zu einem beunruhigenden
Ergebnis gekommen eigentlich ist diese region kaum
erdbebengefährdet doch
2015 und 17 gab es dort jeweils. Ein erdbeben einmal mit der stärke. 2,8
2015 und noch stärker 2017 mit 3,2 auf der momenten-magnituden-skala
Ab 5,0 wird es gefährlich und die beben waren zudem in einer entfernung von 50 kilometern
Noch spürbar aber was hat die erdbeben ausgelöst eigentlich liegt deutschland mitten auf der eurasischen platte
Erdbeben sind hier kaum zu befürchten aber. Eben nur kaum und deutlich weniger in der region. Um, alle gibt es eine geologische
ausnahmeerscheinung die hallische
Marktplatz verwerfung das klingt jetzt nach einem riss im kopfsteinpflaster ist aber bedeutend. Mehr dort haben sich vor mehreren millionen. Jahren
Zwei gesteinsplatten, um mehrere hundert meter in der. Höhe gegeneinander verschoben eigentlich geht von dort keine
erdbebengefahr mehr aus doch die
Neuen erdbeben waisen genau auf diese beiden gesteinsplatten hin die auslöser für die erschütterung lagen nämlich in 22. Beziehungsweise
29 kilometern tiefe die forschungsgruppe ist jetzt sehr besorgt dass solche erdbeben die verwerfung wieder reaktivieren
Könnten, und von dort größere erdbeben ausgelöst werden. Könnten
Und auf solche ereignisse sei man nicht gut vorbereitet so der leiter der erdbeben
Der universität, leipzig sie warf funkel gegenüber focus generell ist in deutschland nur mit wenigen schwachen erdbeben
Zu rechnen doch trotzdem gibt es immer mal wieder welche anfang der 90er. Jahre zum beispiel im rheinland. Wo zahlreiche häuser beschädigt
Wurden, das atomkraftwerk. Mülheim kärlich musste wieder abgeschaltet werden weil der rheingraben zuseher
Erdbebengefährdet ist die naheliegende eifel ist aus geologischer sicht
ein aktives vulkangebiet und erst am vergangenen wochenende gab es einen schwarm beben im vogtland an der grenze zu tschechien also,
Ein beben das aus ganz vielen beben besteht die in kurzer zeit auftreten und das am selben ort es erreichte eine stärke von
3,3 alles in allem ist das risiko gering aber mit der region leipzig. Halle ist ein
Neues gefährdetes erdbebengebiet dazu. Gekommen und dort kann eben schlimmes passieren wenn. Er also nichts zum thema erdbeben in deutschland
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Und den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er kein video denn die abo box auf youtube die ist ja ziemlich
Unvollständig dann erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um, social media abonnieren das geht hier erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt und nicht die genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Neuer kontinent entsteht in afrika ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran